[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe enregistré
ici au parlement européen à bruxelles
notre invité pour cette émission et
christine revault d'allonnes bonne fois
eurodéputé ps d'île de france
ensemble nous évoquerons principalement
la taxation des poids lourds et des
véhicules en europe puisque notre invité
est rapporteur pour la révision de la
directive eurovignette
ou plutôt euros redevance est ce le
retour éventuellement d'une écotaxe en
france nous lui poserons la question
comme à chaque émission de vous
présenterons aussi un personnage
emblématique de la construction de
l'union européenne ce soir luis veille
ce qui fut aussi surnommée la grand-mère
de l'europe
il sera question également de
dépénalisation du cannabis dans cette
émission la question fait à nouveau
débat en france quels sont les choix
faits par nos voisins réponse en fin
d'émission
[Musique]
christine revault d'allonnes bonne foi
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes eurodéputé
depuis 2014 engagé au ps depuis la
campagne présidentielle de lionel jospin
en 1995
vous êtes ancrés localement à villejuif
dans le val-de-marne un ancien bastion
communiste
vous avez été aussi conseiller régional
d'ile-de-france spécialiste des
questions liées au transport depuis de
nombreuses années vous êtes depuis un an
présidente de la délégation socialiste
française
on va parler d'histoire dans quelques
instants avec la découverte du parcours
de louise weiss dit tout avant qu est ce
qui vous a poussé à prendre à embarquer
dans le train de l'union européenne vous
étiez déjà candidate en 2009
ouah avoir décidé de vous consacrer à
l'europe en tant que politique très très
sincèrement je me suis toujours senti
davantage européenne que française ça
peut peut-être choquer mais ma
citoyenneté ma nationalité d'abord
européenne
je pense que c'est lié à ma génération
j'ai grandi à 18 ans il ya eu
l'effondrement du mur de berlin
le rapprochement très fort d'une
construction allemande avec à l'époque
déjà ce couple franco allemand très
important et j'ai trouvé beaucoup plus
de sens à mon engagement mes convictions
dans la vie politique
à ce niveau-là plus beaucoup plus haut
niveau en s'érigeant en politique
c'était déjà un objectif pour vous
l'europe ont été bons ce qui était déjà
une évidence
et quand on a vu la montée de l'extrême
droite qui est maintenant
dernières élections présidentielles
présente au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
on se rend compte que ce repli
nationaliste n'apporte rien de bon et
que les solutions il faut les trouver et
les proposer au niveau européen c'est un
enjeu qui est très important et c'est
pourquoi je suis très heureuse
aujourd'hui d'être au parlement européen
pour avancer sur ces propositions là
l'histoire de l'europe tous les mois de
tv tous les mois tv 78 vous fait
découvrir celles et ceux qui ont
participé à la construction de l'union
européenne ce mois-ci donc louise weiss
qui fut élu en 1979 à l'âge de 86 ans
euro députés appelés la grand-mère de
l'europe les détails de son parcours
avec philippe le guen
le directeur de l'association jean
monnet basée dans les yvelines
[Musique]
alors luis vaz wii n'est pas peut-être
pas très connus bon elle et elle a vécu
90 ans donc elle a été oui la grand-mère
peut-être parce que c'était une des
premières femmes qui est entrée au
parlement européen un peu avant simone
veil et qui accueille d'ailleurs
accueilli simone veil en tant que
douaniers doyenne l'époque jack déclare
donc ouvert la séance constitutive du
parlement européen
mais louise weiss a été très tôt
militante de la cause de la paix elle
était aussi féministe mais c'est pas
forcément le sujet d'aujourd'hui mais
elle a été militant de la cause de la
paix puisqu'elle avait été infirmière
pendant la première guerre mondiale elle
avait vu les horreurs de la guerre et
elle a très tôt voulu croire qu'une paix
durable serait possible entre les deux
guerres ne l'a pas été
ainsi puisqu'on sait que claire au même
moment montait en puissance en allemagne
et que les pacifistes français peut-être
à l'époque d'ailleurs sous-estiment r ce
qui allait réellement se passer
donc elle a été marquée ensuite parce là
et toute sa vie elle a continué à
vouloir oeuvrer pour la paix donc il
était évident que que la construction
européenne la première communauté
européenne en 1950
vous pouvez que que que qu'abonder dans
ce sens elle a continué son métier de
journaliste est par la suite elle a
réhabilité en politique elle a pu
rentrer au parlement européen mais elle
était déjà j'ai évidemment mais je pense
que pour elle c'est une consécration
d'être d'être entré au parlement
européen en ayant eu toute sa vie
l'espoir
enfin qu'on pourrait faire la paix sur
le continent et et vivre en démocratie
vivre libres il me semble à cet instant
n'avoir jamais traversé le siècle et
sillonner le monde que pour venir à
votre rencontre
elle a aujourd'hui un bâtiment au
parlement européen à strasbourg qui
porte son nom
donc c'est un signe de reconnaissance et
il ya aussi un prix du journalisme loose
vs qui est attribué chaque année un prix
européen
[Musique]
louise weiss on l'a vu à travers ce
parcours à travers son histoire a fait
forcément avancer les droits des femmes
et vous christine revault d'allonnes
bonne foi sur votre compte twitter alors
là on fait un saut dans le présent vous
vous présentez comme eurodéputés
socialistes et féministe comment
concrétistes ont cet engagement en
qualité d'eurodéputé avant tout je
voudrais rendre un hommage à une très
grande femme européenne aussi pour le
combat des droits des femmes
je pense à simone veil ont évidemment se
sont côtoyés d'ailleurs toutes les deux
parlements et elles ce sont des exemples
fabuleux sur le combat des droits des
femmes
on le voit ben oui il ya eu l'actualité
ces derniers temps avec les hashtag
mitumba non son port mais la question
des violences faites aux femmes est
vraiment très prégnante en france en
europe
une femme sur trois victimes de
violences en europe donc il y a des
choses à faire nous avons un texte
européen qui est sur la table c'est la
convention d'istanbul pour lequel je
suis rapporteur qui traite de toutes les
questions liées aux violences faites aux
femmes avec un principe 3p prévention
protection et paix et la poursuite de
ceux qui sont les agresseurs de ces
femmes et il y à un combat qui est très
important aujourd'hui je parlais de
simone veil c'est la question du droit à
l'avortement
nous l'avons en france il n'est pas le
même pour toutes les femmes en europe il
ya des ppri c'est en pologne remise en
cause
en pologne il n'y a pratiquement plus de
droits à l'avortement mais il ya aussi
malte où il n'ya pas de droit à
l'avortement il ya aussi l'irlande
donc il y à des combats pour les droits
des femmes qui sont l'actualité encore
aujourd'hui donc être socialiste et
féministe c'est pour moi un engagement
total pour revenir peut-être au débat en
france on sait l'écouter eu qu'a pu
avoir une tribune récemment comment vous
êtes placez vous dans ce débat entre
ceux qui disent que que ça ça a été trop
loin parfois ou alors comment vous êtes
passé vous en tant qu'eurodéputé moi je
trouve ça tout à fait sain qu'il y ait
un certain nombre de femmes qui mettent
sur la table tout ce qu'elles ont vécu
tout ce qu'elles vivent encore
aujourd'hui
c'est tant mieux pour les jeunes filles
d'aujourd'hui qu'elle considère pas ça
comme normal d'être importuné non ce
n'est pas normal
et ce n'est pas un comportement normal
et beaucoup et la majorité des hommes et
des garçons ne sont pas d'accord avec ça
il faut faire de l'éducation il faut ne
plus jamais entendre ça donc cette
tribune m'a choqué revenons-en aux
affaires européennes beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus technique forcément vous
avez été désigné ici au parlement
européen c'était l'été dernier
rapporteur pour la révision de la
directive eurovignette avant de rentrer
dans le détail de ce rapport de faire de
la pédagogie eurovignette c'est un terme
peu connus on le sait du paysage
médiatique
expliquez-nous les grandes lignes de
cette directive d'ailleurs que vous ne
voulez plus qu'on appelle un si vous
voulez qu'on l'appelle heureux redevance
ou alors c'est du jargon technique mais
derrière cela il ya une vraie réalité on
à la situation suivante on prend le
train on prend l'avion dans notre billet
que nous payons comme usagers il ya un
droit d'utilisation de la voie
ferroviaire ou de d'utiliser l'avion
quand on prend la route
il n'y a pas de système de péage partout
en france on connaît et pour nous c'est
une évidence
on va prendre l'autoroute on va prendre
un ticket et on va payer conçoit un
véhicule léger conçoit une moto
convaincu qu'on est une moto ou comme il
est cher certains vous diront qu'on
utilise un camion mais c'est un principe
qui a été accepté par tous parce que en
même temps ça permet
reconstruire rénover les infrastructures
de permettre des parkings des aides
voyages etc
c'est un système qui en france est
acceptée existe il n'existe pas partout
en europe et il y à beaucoup de pays où
ils n'ont toujours pas de système que ce
soit le système du péage comme on
connaît en france où le système à
l'ancienne qu'on a connu nous il ya très
longtemps qui s'appelait la vignette qui
était pas à appuyer sur la distance
parcourue avec un véhicule mais sur une
ia question de la durée voilà à l'année
au mois au jour donc le système
aujourd'hui que proposait le parlement
fin le l'union européenne mais en
général on vit mieux s'appeler
eurovignette parce que s'était appuyé
sur la question de vignette dont sur
cette question durée et ça ne prenait
pas en compte du tout le temps parcouru
et donc lui l'utilisation qu'on pouvait
faire de la route
et quand on utilise la route on la bim
forcément quand il ya beaucoup de
véhicules des poids lourds des véhicules
légers qui utilise elle est abîmée et
qui paye après eh ben ce sont les
contribuables et là dans la proposition
qui est faite c'est précisément de faire
en sorte que celui qu'il utilise
participent à la rénovation vont en
parler de votre rapport mais pour bien
comprendre du coup cette directive le
but de céder face et on va dire la
mauvaise concurrence entre les pays qui
n'appliquent aucun aucun paiement aucune
redevance et puis ceux qui ont un
système on va dire très très très très
serré perdre répondre à deux principes
qui sont dans le livre blanc des
transports dans tous les transports
pollueur payeur utilisateur payeur
il n'y a pas de raison que quand on
prend le train ou quand on prend l'avion
et participent
et quand on prend la voiture où on prend
le camion on participe pas donc il
fallait remettre à plat ça et après
trouver le système le plus acceptable
possible pour que ce soit le cas partout
au sein de l'union européenne et qui est
pas des pays qui l'appliqué de pays qui
ne l'appliquent pas aujourd'hui vise
seulement les poids lourds de 12 tonnes
vous vous proposer d'élargir ce champ là
et de l'appliquer à l'horizon en 2026 à
tous les usages et or devant ce qu'elle
ait quitté l'impact concrètement par
exemple vous le disiez pour un français
ça aurait pas d'impact mais ça a sonné
pour les restes des européens qui les
repoussent une redevance est bien très
concrètement en allemagne ils n'ont pas
de système pour les véhicules légers
donc je sais que pour eux c'est quelque
chose qui au départ les un peu surpris
et il ya des pays où ni les camions ni
les véhicules légers ne l'utilisent mais
après on discutant avec les uns et les
autres il trouve que c'est finalement
assez normal surtout que dans le système
de péage que nous proposons il y a
vraiment une prise en compte de niveaux
de pollution du véhicule si c'est un
véhicule essence ou un véhicule diesel
si ces véhicules diesel de dernière
génération donc moins polluant qu'un
véhicule dix à vingt ou trente ans il
faut prendre en compte tous ces sites
ces critères là pour avoir une grille de
paiement qui soit adaptée à la pollution
du véhicule donc là ce volet pollution
aurait un impact pour les pour l'épauler
pour les français pour les
automobilistes français puisque
aujourd'hui canton pour le maillage on
ne paie pas le exactement où l'on coûts
externes c'est le coup le terme
technique peut-être en tout cas en
économie mais aujourd'hui en france on
met le pas en compte voilà ça pourrait
avoir un coût pour les français votre
votre foi ça pourrait leur coûter moins
cher de prendre l'autoroute s'ils ont un
véhicule qui a un système beaucoup moins
polluant parce que vous soyez roule à
l'hybride soyez rouleau véhicules
électriques soit ils ont un véhicule de
type euro 6 diesel
donc ça leur coûterait moins cher en
réalité vous voudriez que ce soit
appliquée d'ici 2026 c'est-à-dire dans
huit ans voilà je suis en mathématiques
est-ce que c'est dans longtemps je vais
vous dire ce que c'est faisable de
l'appliquer aujourd'hui à tous les
véhicules
alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est dans l'europe
uniquement pour les pour les plus de 12
tonnes c'est l'ambition qu'on d'affilée
ce qui est certain c'est que si on met
en place un système pour les poids
lourds avec des péages puisque on sort
des vignettes et qu'on attend plus
longtemps pour les véhicules légers
ça va être ingérable pour les états
membres ça veut dire qu'ils auront des
systèmes de péage
mais pas pour tous les véhicules c'est
beaucoup plus complexe que de partir du
principe que tout le monde a payé est en
revanche en fonction du type de véhicule
on paye pas la même somme
comment on comment on pourrait voir
justement en fonction du type de
véhicule combien conviant père et ce
serait ignorer des comme au ps j'aurai
des caméras qui vers anfosso votre
véhicule vous paierez moins par exemple
cet exemple là puisqu'on a l'habitude
tous de prendre le péage avec un ticket
oui
on a le ticket et on a aussi maintenant
on le voit dans les parkings de
stationnement l'a prise en photo et bien
sûr de la plaque d'immatriculation à
partir de la plaque d'immatriculation
d'un véhicule
on connaît toutes ces caractéristiques
le type de motorisation et c'est donc ça
va très vite
alors que les nouvelles bornes audio
plus très vite voilà exactement et il y
a aussi des exemptions parce que diront
ses actes à lussas les moyens sont les
véhicules les plus polluants
généralement ceux qui ont moins de
moyens
est-ce que c'est pas discriminatoire
pour pour eux généralement ceux qui ont
le moins de moyens et qui ont absolument
besoin de leur véhicule notamment pour
se rendre à leur travail et il n'y a pas
d'offre de transport en commun
ce que je propose ce sont des exemptions
qui vont jusqu'à 50% du prix du péage
pour tenir compte de la situation
il se trouve en périphérie urbaine et
ils n'ont pas d'autre choix parce qu'on
le sait et même en ile de france et vous
le savez dans les yvelines
oui moi vois certains dans le val d'oise
yvelines il n'y a pas d'offre de
transport en commun donc il faut quand
même aller travailler
heureusement et on n'a pas forcément les
moyens d'accéder à un nouveau véhicule
même s'il ya quand même des aides qui
sont mises en place et qui soit
intéressante nous donnerait un
abattement il faut voilà il y aurait une
exemption qu'il va jusqu'à 50 %
l'argent qui découlerait du coup le
surplus d'argent qui découleraient de
cette nouvelle redevance il ya là la
pollution
comment serait déjà récolté l'argent et
qui le gérait et qu'est ce qu'on en
ferait concrètement de cet argent est ce
que ça permettrait de financer la
recherche par exemple pour les véhicules
propres
alors ce qui est je propose c'est que
l'argent qui est récolté de toutes les
redevances l'infrastructure qu externe
pour les pour les utilisateurs c'est
qu'une seule redevance c'est qu'un seul
péage il faut qu'elle soit directement
orientée vers les transports et que ceux
là soient transparents c'est à dire que
quand la personne va prendre son ticket
il y à un panneau qui explique voilà
vous allez payer mais ça va permettre de
rénover la route
ça va permettre aussi de d'avant de
d'améliorer et de participer au
financement des transports propres
les transports en commun tout ce qui
aujourd'hui fait difficulté et on s'en
rend compte il une actualité c'est le
nouveau grand paris nous on ne sait pas
quand les nouvelles lignes de nouveau
paré paris seront mises en circulation
dans les si elles sont mises en
circulation et qui finance ça pourrait
participer à cela et donc c'est un moyen
de faire comprendre et de faire accepter
par tous ce paiement donc ce serait très
simple ce serait un affichage qui serait
propose les questions liées aux
transports on l'a vu au moment de la
directive des travailleurs détachés
c'est une question sensible en europe on
a vu des blocs se détacher sur votre
rapport à vous qu en est il est ce qu'il
ya des blocs aussi est ouest qui sont
qui sont marqués sur ce sujet là que
vous disent vos collègues à la
commission des transports et bien ça
dépend un exemple les allemands on en
parlait tout à l'heure
on a une très grande différence
culturelle des allemands et nous sur la
vitesse limite c'est que la paillade et
il ya des autos limitation est pour eux
l'utilisation de la voiture c'est
quelque chose qui est très très fort
donc qui sont assez heurtée par ma
proposition de faire participer tous les
utilisateurs de la route et y compris
les voitures donc là j'ai une difficulté
qu revanche je n'ai pas avec ma collègue
roumaine pour lesquels c'est vrai sur
les questions sociales nous sommes pas
toujours d'accord mais qui la
considèrent cela comme normal donc ce
sera pas forcément est ouest mais plutôt
par rapport à des pratiques et l'amour
de la voiture ou pas qu'on peut avoir
dans certains pays l'allemagne très
clairement comme l'autriche
il aime les voitures ils sont souvent
peu en possession d'un véhicule privé et
ils sont assez hostile à cette idée mais
je vais développer tous les arguments
possibles pour les convaincre du bien
fondé
la ministre des transports et les ébène
bornes dans le cadre de la future loi
mobilité s'est dit favorable à
l'instauration de péages urbains en
france on pourrait comme à londres par
exemple payer pour rentrer en voiture à
paris à marseille à lille quelle est
votre position sur ce débat qui est
lancée en france est ce que vous trouvez
que ça va dans le bon sens puisque là
aussi on parle de péage oui mais je
tiens à préciser que dans mon rapport il
n'en est pas question absolument pas le
sujet et je pense en tout cas pour vivre
en ile de france est pour ne pas être
parisienne je pense que c'est une forme
de discrimination vis-à-vis de ceux qui
viennent de banlieue au sein de paris
donc j'y suis à titre personnel pas
forcément favorable après j'ai vu
l'exemple de stockholm qui est assez
intéressant et qui est intéressant
pourquoi parce qu'il a été fait avec
beaucoup de discussions consultation
avec les habitants de stockholm et de la
périphérie stockholm et finalement ça a
été accepté mais sûre en tout cas sur ce
qui concerne la situation de paris je
pense que ce sera très compliqué
une question très rapidement vous
parliez des élections est ce que vous
serez candidate à un nouveau mandat en
2019 est ce que vous le souhaitez déjà
est ce que je le souhaiterais beaucoup
je laime récent du ps
bien sûr c'est ma famille c'est à dire
hier pour cent du quercy serait fier et
après le choix il appartient aux
militants de mon parti c'est comme ça
que nous choisissons les candidats on en
vient maintenant à notre rubrique et
chez nos voisins ça se passe comment
avec un débat qui ne cesse de perdurer
en france autour du cannabis et qui
reprend forme avec un rapport
parlementaire récent qui préconise la
mise en place d' amendes pour les
consommateurs en france 17 millions de
personnes auraient fumé au moins une
fois du cannabis qu'elle et l'arsenal
juridique dont disposent nos voisins
européens éléments de réponse avec
olivier jeanne l'ex responsable du
centre europe direct à saint germain en
laye
[Musique]
alors aucun pays de l'union européenne
n'a légaliser le cannabis a aucun pays
par contre on a des situations
différentes où on a des pays qui ont été
on va dire coûts qui sont beaucoup plus
souples et beaucoup plus laxiste dans la
pénalisation
alors on a certains pays où c'est
strictement illégal de posséder ou
consommé du cannabis
on peut penser notamment à certains pays
de l'est ou en fonction de la quantité
que vous avez par exemple si vous
dépassez 5 g ou 7,5 g ça dépend vraiment
des pays
là vous avez des peines de prison qui
peuvent s'appliquer par exemple vous
allez en autriche si vous possédez sur
vous une certaine dose de cannabis vous
risquez jusqu'à un an de prison
si vous allez en gris ou à chypre vous
pouvez avoir des peines de prison qui
sont beaucoup plus lourdes
on a certains pays qui ont maintenu un
statut juridique un statut pénal sur le
cannabis qui est assez fort par contre
on a des pays qui sont beaucoup plus
lents beaucoup plus souple pas forcément
laxistes ou du moins qui vont pénaliser
beaucoup moins n'a par exemple le cas en
espagne ou aux pays bas où la
consommation de cannabis on va dire dans
une
dans un cadre privé chez soi n'est pas
forcément n'est pas forcément pénalisé
pareil le fait d'avoir une certaine dose
du généralement c'est des doses
inférieures à 5 grammes sur soi ça ne va
pas provoquer de peines de prison par
contre vous aurez juste une simple
amende à payer alors un ressortissant
européen est obligé de suivre la
législation en vigueur dans le pays dans
lequel il se trouve
c'est le principe c'est le principe de
base c'est la liberté des uns s'arrête
là où commence celle des autres
donc quand on va dans un pays on
applique sa législation
donc c'est pas un scoop on a beaucoup de
français qui vont justement aux pays bas
afin de profiter du système des coffee
shops parce que c'est beaucoup plus
c'est beaucoup plus tolérés par rapport
à par rapport à nous en france par
contre si revient en france
ils appliquent la législation française
et sachant que si quand on part des pays
bas et qu'on revient en france en
fonction du trajet qui fait il peut
traverser l'allemagne peut traverser la
belgique s'il se fait contrôler à la
frontière allemande ou à la frontière à
la frontière belge
il sera soumis à la législation
allemande ou à la législation belge qui
ont une législation radicalement
différente par rapport à ce qui
s'applique aux pays bas
[Musique]
en tant qu'eurodéputé est ce que c'est
un sujet qui vous intéresse que vous
regardez ce que vous avez une position
là dessus on sait que le ps a souvent
été en avance sur ces questions là il ya
eu beaucoup de débats au sein de votre
parti vous est ce que vous estimez que
la france c'est un peu le débat
d'aujourd'hui va trop loin et trop
répressive sur sur le sujet du cannabis
et qu'il faudrait un peu changé de
prisme pour pour pour lutter contre les
drogues en france mais je pense qu'il
ferait vraiment changé de prismes par
rapport au cannabis pas par rapport aux
drogues d'une façon générale mais sur la
question du cannabis c'est pas de cette
manière là qu'on va arrêter la
consommation de cannabis notamment par
les jeunes en france il faudrait
peut-être mieux s'intéresser à la façon
dont le commerce de cannabis est fait et
tant qu'on interdira de cette manière là
on laissera ce fonctionnement cette
vente qui est là et qui représente des
sommes astronomiques donc mais pour moi
c'est absolument pas la bonne voie à
suivre
et encore une fois il faut faire la
différence entre le cannabis et les
autres drogues plus se concentrer sur ma
fille quand vous dites mais c'est même
au delà de ça il faut regarder le
consommateur est effectivement celui qui
va en faire le commerce mais il en fait
le commerce pourquoi précisément parce
que c'est interdit
donc la question il faut la poser
autrement il faut peut-être regarder le
cannabis et à se poser la question par
rapport à l'alcool
on a un regard s'est différencié les
français lassés et il n'empêche que il
a des vertus thérapeutiques haute au
cannabis je suis pas en train de dire
fumée tous du cannabis et simplement on
a une vision qui est peut-être pas tout
à fait qu' être toujours très simpliste
de dire on va interdire on va faire la
répression pour réglera pas le problème
comme ça donc il faudrait de la bordée
d'une façon beaucoup plus globale
dernier module de cette émission la
question d'un élu local qui vous
interpellent en tant que député sur la
problématique de son choix
je vous propose de l'écouter en cliquant
j'ai regardé bonsoir madame la députée
je suis grégoria restiez maire de
maurepas et vice président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et j'ai une question très
simple c'est comment l'europe peut-elle
aider les collectivités dans une période
de baisse des dotations de l'état a
réussi reprennent leurs habitants je
vous remercie
c'est un sujet forcément que vous
connaissez bien en tant que qu'élu local
en tout cas vous l'avez été notamment à
la région il ya beaucoup de
collectivités qui s'inquiètent de la
baisse de leurs dotations et ce depuis
de nombreuses années que peut faire
l'europe est ce que vous pouvez aider
financièrement les collectivités locales
les mairies notamment alors déjà vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir que l'union
européenne les le budget l'union
européenne aujourd'hui puisqu'il n'a
toujours pas de ressources propres
malheureusement vient de la contribution
des états membres et que les états
membres et la france en particulier est
en train de revoir à la baisse son
niveau de contribution dont les
contributions vers les politiques de
cohésion et donc tout ce que l'union
européenne fait en tant que financement
auprès des collectivités locales parce
qu elle le fait sur la base de projets
ça
passe évidemment par les régions mais il
y a beaucoup de financements européens
qui sont en direction des collectivités
locales sauf qu'aujourd'hui si vous
regardez le budget qui a porté par la
france en direction de l'union
européenne et qui ensuite repart vers
l'ensemble des collectivités européennes
y compris françaises est en baisse
puisque la priorité est affichée en
direction de la défense et la sécurité
donc vous voulez dénoncer ça on dit on
je ne dénonce pas le fait que la défense
et la sécurité
ce que je dénonce c'est qu'il se soit
fait à budget constant et donc ça veut
dire au détriment des politiques de
cohésion y compris les politiques en
faveur des collectivités locales donc je
comprends très bien cette colère on vit
la même chose et c'est une réelle
injustice et donc il faut rappeler que
quand on considère que l'europe est une
priorité
il ya les actes les discours et si les
actes pouvaient être cohérent avec les
discours qui ont été prononcés avant
c'est mieux merci christine revault
d'allonnes bonne foi d'avoir participé à
ce 7,8 europe je rappelle que vous êtes
eurodéputés socialistes d'ile-de-france
présidente de la délégation socialiste
française ici au parlement européen
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission
replay sur notre site internet est là
commenté sur nos réseaux sociaux tv
soixante dix huit la semaine prochaine
vous retrouverez le 7-8 politique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]